some more great points that you had your
top five takeaways from this week three
that we just got out of start you with
number five you said the afc west the
best division in football why'd you say
it who's catching your eye
man the raiders first and foremost
they're undefeated now did you call that
jack did you call that the raiders are
going to be undefeated i mean you i mean
john gruden has done a wonderful job you
talk about defensively that's where i'm
really excited um yannick nagaway max
crosby casey hayward those guys that's
flat out balling and i never thought
that raiders defense would transform
into what it's transformed into and i
don't know the stats and all the
statistics and all that all i know is
when i see them play they got 11 guys
flying around hitting cheering one
another just getting around the ball
creating turnovers and making plays i
love to see it number two i'm looking at
the denver broncos teddy b
his teammates absolutely love him every
time you hear one of his teammates talk
about him
they always talk about his leadership
and how calm he is and the just the
calmness that he brings um to the
offense and then of course
the chargers brandon staley has this
team focused and before anthony lynn and
all those other coaches before they
couldn't finish you saw him always get
penalized penalties and fumbles and just
bad football brandon staley has this
team believing they've always been a
naturally talented team but now this
head coach and i think he's going to do
a wonderful job he has these guys
finishing and believing in themselves
i think the chargers might
we hit on the raiders we've hit on vegas
heavily on this show and it's it's
because they have been real and derek
carr is playing playing the best
football that we've seen him ever play
and so i think we're giving them you
know fair love there over 400 passing
yards he's throwing four in every single
game his car he leads the league in
passing yards by a substantial margin
he's ahead of tom brady who's right
there in the second slot by substantial
margins i think that's all been real
the the aggressiveness with which the
chargers played the chiefs caught my
attention the way that every time it was
a fourth down and in field goal range
and they could go tie the game with the
field goal but they're not worried about
that they're going for it they want
seven they just were constantly putting
this chiefs defense on their heels and i
thought what they did defensively
defending patrick holmes look at some of
these throws by herbert put it up high
mike williams keenan allen finally
watched these guys have a quarterback
just put it up high how many times we're
watching this game rod did you see these
monsters on the outside for the chargers
just ripping balls out of the air like
rebounds they're just going up and
stealing it away and that's how they
ended up taking this game from the
chiefs
brother and i'm gonna tell you this as
much as i'm excited about with williams
and allen and all the weapons they have
their left tackle
and it just slipped my name rashaan
slater
this kid is going to be special okay i
watched him block chris jones i watched
him the first two weeks and he is just
he's going to be an outstanding left
tackle he's a rookie so now you have
you're going to have one of the best
left tackles in all of football playing
on a rookie deal for the next four to
five years i'm just really pumped up
about the chargers and what they're
doing on the offensive line and what
justin herbert like when he first
started remember last year when he found
out like 10 minutes before
and i'm like
and i saw him play and he was just he
went out there and he just bought out i
said the charger should never go back to
the backup quarterback like this guy is
special and i think that's what we're
seeing
he is special and i want to ask you this
too because we're seeing a new defensive
scheme going up against kansas city
offensively and it's working and what
they're doing and what the chargers did
they're sitting back in these two
safeties two deep safeties and they're
going run the ball great do what you
want to do take 10 15 completions to go
down the fields beautiful go do it all
day if you want to but we're not getting
beat by one 80-yard bomb to tyrique or
to kelsey over the top that's wrecking
the whole game they're gonna make you
nickel and dime and earn it and it seems
to be working they're forcing some bad
mistakes out of my homes and in others
clyde edwards e lair starting to have a
fumbling problem is there a new playbook
defensively that's starting to work
against kc
well it's it's not a new playbook
because if you remember correctly when
we're in baltimore i told you the same
exact thing
keep two safeties back make sure you box
in one man the man on tyreek hill get
one guy that you know will challenge him
will will be up in his hip every single
play and keep a safety deep that's what
you do and you eliminate those big plays
then andy reed has to come up with more
creative ways um you know um jet sweeps
and things like that to get him the ball
but he's not catching those 60 70 yard
bombs and when you eliminate that then
what do they do they go to travis kelsey
they wear him out in the middle of the
field but ultimately it comes down to
eliminating those big plays and if you
can eliminate those big plays and you
can get to my homes and you can start
frustrating him you see those crazy
passes
what they call 50 50 balls or 80 20
balls you know what now if you come up
with a couple of those you're going to
end up winning the game but the key here
it wasn't just the chargers defense but
their but their offense because their
offense put constant pressure on kansas
city's defense and they were able to
come out and constantly put pressure on
them because of the skill guys that they
have whether it's jared cook whether
it's allen whether it's williams outside
in its back-to-back weeks now that we've
seen casey have a chance really a great
chance to go win the game late the
baltimore
game they're driving right at the end of
the fourth quarter elaire fumbles they
lose that game in this one patrick
mahomes about 217 on the clock chance to
drive it down just need a field goal to
go win it he lofts that one just trying
to do too much to kelsey winds up being
an interception so
it comes down to those last drives just
like we saw aaron rodgers do to go win
it in the last couple weeks mahomes and
casey have not been able to do it let's
get to aaron rodgers you said
looking at rogers we were just there san
francisco green bay we were both on the
packers even though we thought all signs
point to san francisco winning this game
one side didn't have aaron rodgers the
other side did we both went with the
packers what are you seeing from that
offense you said you noticed some
weaknesses even in the w
yeah i mean i look at the packers they
need help they need help in the passing
game they need another receiver when
devonte adams went down when he went
down he had 12 catches and i think 18
targets when he went down
everybody was like oh if he doesn't come
back this game is over that's how
valuable he is he is an outstanding
receiver you could play him inside you
can play him outside and everything that
you throw to him he basically comes down
with and i'll tell you this aaron
rodgers when he threw that deep dig over
the linebacker in that two-minute drill
and he completed it and it set them up
for um i think it was another play or
maybe the field goal but that deep dig
that he put right over the linebacker it
was the best throw that i've seen all
year it was just absolutely incredible
but they're going to need help because
asking devante adams for 18 targets
every single week with injuries
hamstrings and all those different
things that's a tough ass if i'm the if
i'm the packers i'm going out trying to
trade for me a veteran wide receiver or
a receiver that can come in and make an
impact
or how about just draft one and that's
the thing is they may have to go make
and do one of those last second shifts
and shakes with the roster because it
all goes back to when aaron was
originally matt and what it was was they
drafted a power running back in the
second round and aj dillon who has done
nothing to go contribute to a
championship ready roster and in the
first round that same draft a year ago
they took jordan love a backup
quarterback so those are two wasted
draft picks two guys that have done
nothing nothing in terms of helping this
team go chase championships and it was
rounds one and two of the draft and now
you're looking at the roster and you're
going well they could really use a tight
end i understand tonya is working his
way into the circle of trust but he
doesn't scare you and besides devonte
adams there's nobody else that you think
about other than maybe aaron jones
coming out of the backfield so it is
deficient with weapons especially when
you start talking about well they got to
go beat tom brady and the bucks who have
a million guys they got to go beat
kansas city and patrick mahomes who have
a million guys so the top of the nfl has
so many weapons that i don't know if
they can hang with them given what they
have
i look at aj dillon who you just
mentioned and we were watching the game
and as a defensive player i'm saying
this is the guy that i want in the game
i want aj dylan you know why because
he's big he's stiff and if if he doesn't
get going you can you could just grab
his his his legs and he he'll go down
you don't have to really necessarily
worry about him in as a receiver out of
the backfield but when you put aaron
jones in there all of a sudden he can
become a receiver
screens you know he can run in between
the tackles he can do a multitude of
things and and i i was just like okay aj
dylan he's a big dude but you could have
picked that up in the fifth or sixth
round you didn't have to use a second
round draft choice and like you talked
about he gives them nothing absolutely
nothing no explosiveness um and he
doesn't even run like he's 250 pounds
like he's six foot 250 and when i'm
looking at him he looks like he's
running like he's a a 205 running back
like and aaron actually aaron jones runs
harder than aj dylan period
he does he does and dylan's got about 70
pounds on him got about 70 pounds on him
and so many times you see aaron jones
dragging people with them or breaking a
tackle and getting another seven or
eight yards aj dillon it seems like
almost every time he hits that pile and
you're expecting him to move it you
expect him to be derek henry and go push
the whole pile or break out of it and he
just kind of gets ushered to the ground
almost every time and that's that's
pretty dang high to pick a running back
period but to pick a power running back
in a passing offense that doesn't have a
bunch of power on the nfl field it was
just a tough pick and now they keep
trying to cover up for the mistake and
play them and it's digging them even
deeper let's go to your third headline
the cowboys that's a team who was
hammering the football dallas the best
team in the nfc east you say monday
night football look pretty darn good
against philly
they did i got to give dan quinn
defensive coordinator a lot of props
he's come in and really changed the
identity he told me when we're week one
in tampa he walked up to me he told me
says rodney i'm not the same coach that
i used to be i used to be cover three
and pretty predictable he says now we're
doing a ton of different things we're
running blitzes man coverage zone
coverage so you don't know what you're
gonna get you might get two safeties
deep you might get two safeties blitzing
so dan quinn is doing a multitude of
thing the other person i want to give
props to is dak prescott the leadership
and toughness that he shows the mental
toughness that he shows every single
week his teammates think about his
teammates when they saw him go down and
they saw every basically every ounce of
rehab that he had to go through
every single day him bumping and
grinding doing everything he had to do
to get back on on the football field how
can you not play hard how can you not
play tough when you see this guy doing
everything he can to get back on the
football field that's why a lot of props
has to go to dak prescott his leadership
and his toughness shows week in and week
out
he's been phenomenal i mean you think
about going toe-to-toe with tom brady in
tampa coming right off the super bowl we
were there for that game those fans were
going insane that night and he went
toe-to-toe throw for throw with the goat
then he goes to la knocks off the
chargers then he comes back home against
philly and puts on that type of
performance where they just hammered him
they were running the ball any time they
wanted to they were throwing the ball
wherever they wanted to put it cd lam
amari cooper doing their thing schultz
the tight ends playing well right now
pollard zeke elliott coming out of the
backfield that's a good one-two punch
and then the offensive line has just
looked great it's looking like it's
returning to a dominant offensive line
tyron smith you know zach martin back on
the inside they have been dominators
what are you seeing up front because
this this how this football team was
built they were such a good offensive
line are they getting back to their
dominant ways with those five up front
man you know me don't you you know when
you start talking offensive line because
nobody talks offensive line except the
fat guys are retired but i love the
offensive line and zach martin let me
tell you i got a chance to sit back and
just watch him play just watch him and
the job that he did on fletcher cox and
just
just the consistency and toughness and
the way he moves moves these guys i'm
like
like you pay attention to him and you
almost take for granted how good he is
but this guy is great i'm talking about
hall of fame type talent man i'm really
pumped up about their um their offensive
line and what they what they were able
to accomplish because that's a tough
defensive front
that's who dallas is and they've hit on
two great defensive picks too micah
parsons and diggs how about diggs over
at corner second round pick back in 2020
alabama i don't know if you're listening
to the peyton and eli broadcast last
night but they had sabin on talking
about digs while he's making some of
these plays he reminds me of jalen
ramsey a little bit like he is a
physical freak a physical dominator on
the outside three interceptions as well
leads the whole league
man i was so pumped up with him because
you know he has the talent you know and
and we just kind of waiting for that dog
to come out and then when i saw what i
saw last night you hit it perfectly that
was jalen ramsey a guy that was up in
his ex teammates face devonte smith
talking trash pick six um jalen hurts up
in his face talking trash playing with
emotion playing physical and this kid is
intent on being one of the top if not
the top cornerback in the national
football league so i love what i saw
from him when you get a corner playing
like that trust me as a safety as a
defensive player i'm getting pumped i'm
like okay let me join into action and
that's what you see when you see micah
parsons when you see diggs playing on
that level pretty special man i give a
lot of props give a lot of props to dan
quinn because he's got these boys
balling right now
i agree with do you think about parsons
starting the year linebacker now he's
one of the best pass rushers in the
entire league 15 pressures leads the
whole defense there in dallas bunch of
quarterback hits and hurries as well
over in pittsburgh that's a front that's
known for getting a bunch of pressure as
well but so far it has been rough for
the pittsburgh steelers let's hear from
mike tomlin the head coach he says
they're not hitting that panic button
quite yet here he was out there
man we're not going to push the panic
button what do i mean by the panic
button you know we're not going to
dramatically change who and what we are
at this juncture
we're not resisting to change for the
purposes of getting better but we're not
going to be so unsteady that we move
away from our compass the identity that
we worked hard to develop and we'll
continue to work hard to develop and in
the emphasis on the style of play
whatever that may be in all three phases
okay so they're not hitting the panic
button yet
but how did you hear that rod i i love
when you play right off the head coach
what'd you hear right there
no i just i really don't know what he
was talking about he was kind of going
in circles but my whole point would be
if a coach is accountability okay it's
not about hitting a panic button but
it's about going to your offensive line
and holding those guys accountable and
guys that aren't playing well you have
to rotate them you have to start
switching them out giving other guys
opportunities big ben let's face it mike
he looks terrible he looks old he looks
old he looks indecisive he looks nervous
back there he looks uncomfortable behind
that offensive line and you go out and
you get i said this last week the
absolute perfect
running back for your system and you can
barely use them because you can't you
can't block for them
and they go and they have this entire
offseason you pay tj watt one guy 28
million dollars a year but you disregard
your offensive line and i just it's not
gonna happen when you have a old stiff
quarterback that can barely move get out
of bed behind that offensive line it's
just going to be very very difficult
for them to get rectified brother
yeah without tj watt it's going to be
hard to begin with cam hayward's been
great again he's been so dominant over
his whole career there in pittsburgh
he's having one of the best starts of
his career melvin ingram's been good
coming over from the chargers but until
t.j watt gets back defensively it's
going to be hard alex highsmith also
missed the cincinnati game as well so
that's two really big pieces they were
playing i don't worry about this patty
bengals
yeah yeah it because it's not gonna
matter when you are going all in on ben
roethlisberger who is a play extension
quarterback who can't extend plays
anymore and that's a problem and they've
had so many years now he's been falling
off for three years they've had three
years to start lining up this succession
plan who's going to be next draft
somebody bring in a free agent bring in
somebody that you can believe in as a
backup that can become a starter and
there's still nobody on that roster that
can be that guy let's get to the buffalo
bills because every time i watch josh
allen play this is when i realized how
far big ben's fallen off because it's
sort of what big ben used to be was he
as athletic maybe not quite as athletic
but he was as big and he was able to
break tackles back there and he's able
to create second plays the buffalo bills
you're calling him the class of the afc
right now why
well because of him first and foremost
he's the best quarterback in the afc and
he's missed some some deep down the
field throws early in a couple games but
now he has a special connection with
emmanuel sanders the secondary is
starting to pick up they're creating
turnovers and they're going to continue
to try to improve that run game but
having um gabriel davis um cole beasley
having all these different weapons it's
not like even stefan diggs is having a
you know having big big games but when
you can kind of spread the wealth you
make that offense incredibly difficult
to handle and i look at buffalo and with
josh extending plays making plays and
doing the things that he's doing i like
the buffalo bills right now as the class
even though they've lost one
and receiver was a weakness for them and
that's why they made out and went out
they made that trade tried to bring in
stefan diggs to become their number one
wide receiver and then another big
offseason pickup that they made was
emanuel sanders and you thought that he
might go down there to new orleans last
season have a huge year with drew brees
didn't really pan out in that way now he
comes to buffalo he's in his 30s well
into his 30s now but he's exploding a
bit i mean he's finding a great
partnership here with josh allen and
it's working i just thought alan threw
some laser beams in that game and he
does it on the move and he's so
comfortable back there he's standing
tall like we see tom brady do but he's
never worried i think it's the size
factor he's never worried that
somebody's going to get a big hit on him
because he's bigger than all these
defensive linemen he's like how many
times you see a quarterback that when
he's moving and alignment gets an arm on
him he just knocks it off and he's
faster he's able to create you know
space to go make another throw point or
make a throw on the run he is as
physically and imposing of a quarterback
as we've seen since cam newton the
difference is he can actually throw the
ball too it's a scary combination
oh man let me tell you you name me one
guy that's tough one quarterback that's
tougher than him
i
i don't see it you tell me one
quarterback physically more
tougher than this guy he just he's a
handful and you talked about you
compared him to big ben i played against
big ben when big ben came in as a rookie
we kicked their butts too picked them
off 87 yards to the house i had to
mention that
but when big ben came in as a rookie he
was the same way chasing him around and
coach belichick would always tell us
when we watch tape don't tackle around
the ankles don't tackle around the
thighs don't even tackle around the hips
tackle his arms because he's always up
there and he's always pushing you off
but if you go tackle his arms he can't
go anywhere so that's one of the lessons
that we had to learn to play against big
man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports